the writing and history is on the wall
here the offices of power to 54 it's the
focus for a new generation of young
Kenyan political activists Boniface
mangey runs the organization which uses
the full force of modern communications
to protest against corruption and
nepotism so unless there's an act
whistles alone I was this artist
photographer come activist was green
things on his own they realize that if
there's a community where people like me
worked every day and interacted with
other people we could actually build a
movement more than a quarter of a
million people follow him on Twitter he
uses the platform to target
controversial issues and often
criticizes the government the 32 year
old is active across social media but
his work goes far beyond what he does
online he organized discussions and also
demonstrations are most memorable
protests that I'll never forget is there
acapella like a primary school how where
the deputy president of this country had
grabbed a school playground to be
Lopakhin and he went there to join the
kids to claim back the playground there
were police officers were armed they
threw tear gas of the kids but the kids
never gave up and they came back and
retained but the playground the social
media base his built-up has given him a
global reach 26-year old sarum alia is
from Malta she decided she wants to work
for power after watching a documentary
about Boniface two years ago she started
as an intern now she's employed there
everything that we do here has that a
bit of an activist twist you know so how
do you use you know how do you use
social media for social change yeah how
do you use social media to speak about
different social injustice justices that
are happening within Kenya so a lot of
our trainings do focus on that more than
100,000 young people have now taken part
in workshops run by power under the
slope
team courage although he's not the only
one working there boniface ing himself
is an important part of why they come so
yes I think he's a role model and not
affect you know a role model for young
people to say no we're not going to do
this anymore this is not right a role
model for people who wants change in
their country my dears for the future I
would like to play a bigger role in
there in the governance of this country
or get to a place or a public position
we have a more defined role in the work
that I do he works into the night
building influence he hopes to use to
help Kenya's youth play a part in the
future of their country